hey Roger you're a great guy he's just
not quite commissioning material time to
step down buddy you're not of me time to
step down fuck you in the Cardinal bitch
I just think that he should be honest
and he should have said what was right I
mean not because we're women or whatever
but these are football players and they
can't go around just slapping women
around and thinking them that's right
you know what I mean if I was an
accountant and I hit my wife I wouldn't
lose my job she hit him first haha and
any bicha hits a guy knows that he's
going to get a punchbag gotta say it
they're doing a great job keep the guy
stop the crap thank you the players are
already put up on a pedestal and he's
covering for all the crap that they do
and doesn't teach anyone anything good
especially my kids hey anybody that can
make nine million dollars tax-free is a
freaking boss tax-free nine mil billion
or is it million 29 million tax free
come on out he's the boss ok mr. to get
down you need some standard operating
procedures for
domestic violent headed shooter that's
what most companies do ignorance is no
excuse his own words he needs to step
down it kind of makes it seem as though
they've been giving a break to all these
guys who've been putting their hands on
women so it's not a good look I feel
like most commissioners in any league or
just corporate lawyers don't really care
about the game there's more or less
collecting paychecks and whatnot but I
just want to watch football and stop
deal with all this bullshit these are
guys r mo time meters there any
different from me and this gentleman
here we don't make millions but it's the
same standard you don't go beating on a
woman and then cover it up would you
care for me smack their wife why would
you care just say you know what you
messed up you made a mistake just like
all the players say you know what we did
what we did just get over it now all of
a sudden because the public outcry
you're doing something for people asking
for your job come on come on Roger come
on Roger don't be a defense attorney
that's the good thing though defend all
those criminals are putting their hands
on their wives there you go I'm done
you're not
want more download the aj+ mobile app
and join the conversation available in
your app store now